y en la votación que será el día de hoy
de acuerdo a lo previsto sale benjamín
netanyahu
que va a significar esto para israel
después de 12 años al frente con
netanyahu y 4 elecciones en menos de dos
años
claro bueno antes que nada muy buenos
días y gracias por invitarme desde sant
que que se interrumpa un periodo de
gobierno tan largo implica una apuesta
por una serie de continuidades y
rupturas un desafío importante para esta
coalición tan ecléctica que hemos
marcadas en ver en qué forma se puede
reconfigurar la agenda sobre todo en
cuestiones claves y sensibles a la
política de asentamientos donde se
espera que exista una continuidad
asimismo una línea también continua
respecto al repudio del estado de israel
frente al acercamiento entre estados
unidos e irán respecto al acuerdo
nuclear que se había logrado en la era
de barack obama por otro lado la
composición heterogénea y diversa de
esta nueva potencial coalición que
parece que sin embargo si será
ratificada con lo menos hasta ahora creo
que lo que resultaría será ver cómo
puede existir presión desde algunos
partidos de izquierdas de centro y de
rahm la lista árabe unida en favor de
algunas políticas más progresistas con
respecto
la población árabe israelí quizás
tendientes a mejorar entonces sus
condiciones de vida
ignacio cuál es el rumbo que debe tomar
el próximo gobierno que estaría a la
cabeza el ultranacionalista naftalí
bennett frente a la crisis permanente
con las milicias de hamás además de la
escalada que vimos en los últimos días
una preocupación en ciertos sectores de
la izquierda que inclusive componen la
colisión es que la retórica de naftalí
bennett es incluso más belicista y más
confrontativa aún y dispuesta a recursos
más extremos que la de el propio
benjamín italiano más allá que hayamos
visto episodios de enfrentamientos
'tenemos repetitivos a lo largo de estos
12 años de gobierno suyo nunca hubo una
guerra total si ese es un punto
importante para marcar porque bennett
en distintas oportunidades y se
manifestó proclive los propensos a
llegar a una solución mucho más tremenda
entonces habrá que ver si pesa la
moderación de parte de esa coalición
revuelta que puede a leonard desde
distintas aristas algo más moderado o
bien inclinarse por un tono como decía
tal vez más radical que la del propio de
tania o ahora como bien lo veníamos
hablando el gobierno de coalición que
tomaría posesión hoy si se mantiene en
lo pactado reúne partidos de todo el
espectro político incluido también como
usted lo decía el árabe que sería el
primero en entrar al gobierno qué peso
tendrían en la knesset que cuenta con
120 parlamentarios
bien efectivamente no esto no les otorga
un peso tan
tan nuevo tan contundente en todo caso
es una cuestión más bien simbólica pero
que si lo que puedes puede traducirse es
en una serie de políticas que como decía
contemplen las necesidades y las
demandas de la población árabe israelí
más que nada vinculada a cuestiones de
presupuesto sobre temas tales como salud
educación y fundamentalmente a lo que
apunta la lista árabe unida que en el
pactar con la coalición de de benet y de
la pide es en conseguir una política más
favorable que revea la ley caminito es
decir que de alguna forma revise la
política de desalojos y demoliciones de
viviendas tanto en el desierto del negro
para la población beduina como para
distintas localidades de dentro del
estado
y particularmente en jerusalén este